let me pull up the story here I was uh
reading from the NBC News Mississippi
Governor signs Bill Banning transgender
health care for minors you see how NBC
News frames it let's try it another way
let's uh I'll give you a different
headline Mississippi Governor signs Bill
Banning child genital mutilation miners
cannot consent
like huh it says in the name children if
they're children they're minors they
can't consent they're not they cannot
well the issue is the parents can
because the parents can send to it
so here's what it says
Mississippi on Tuesday begin the seventh
state to enact a restriction on certain
transition related health care for
minors Governor Tate Reeves Republican
said he signed the bill which bars
puberty blockers hormone therapy and
surgery for minors because there is a
dangerous movement spreading across
America today it's advancing under the
guise of a false ideology and
pseudoscience is being pushed onto our
children through radical activists
social media and online influencers and
it's trying to convince our children
that they are in the wrong body this
dangerous movement attempts to convince
these children that they're just a
surgery away from happiness it threatens
our children's innocence and it
threatens their health
it's crazy he invited uh Matt Walsh from
the daily wire to speak
and the crazy thing is I was talking to
Ali London last week on the culture War
podcast and uh he was saying that he
thought the surgery would make him happy
and he kept getting different plastic
surgeries wondering when he would
finally feel happy and it wasn't working
because the issue isn't the surgery
but the thing is for for Ali I think he
only really got the facial cosmetic
stuff done so many of these young girls
and uh young males have permanently
removed healthy organs they will not be
able to ever have they'll never have
them again and so this is permanently
sterilized some of these kids like jazz
Jennings and Kim Petras will never have
children never have children billions of
years of evolution ends right there with
those individuals and you know what that
three-year-old Jazz did not know that
seven-year-old Jazz did not know that
and I wonder if there's going to come a
point in the lives of these these these
poor people when they're in their 20s
thinking how do I have kids and it's
like well we removed that from you
because you were seven and you said you
wanted it removed
seven years old and then at 17 both I
believe Petrus may have been 16 and Jazz
was 17. they have both been 17 but those
are minors these are under the age of
majority were given genital removal what
do you call it um
testicular ectomy or something like that
the surge of castration but like there's
like there's got to be an ectomy word
for it right like a hysterectomy the
other hysterectomy yeah like women have
hysterectomies and bilateral
ovarectomies or something like the
ovarectomies or whatever you ovarian
removal yeah I mean this it's just we
need to stop you know the whole phrase
right now is stop trans and kids I think
we need to stop transiting people in
general but it starts with kids I think
a society is judged on how they treat
their most innocent and there are many
things in our society that we deem
inappropriate or harmful to children
that regardless of the parents intent
regardless of the parents wishes we
don't allow them to engage in right we
don't give them alcohol just because the
parent says that this is acceptable or
that my child identifies as an adult and
therefore I can give them alcohol we
don't allow kids to be shown pornography
or to even go to R-rated movies or to
download these R-rated video games but
for some some reason under the guise of
this lgbtq movement under the guise of
gender affirming care or the pride flag
we are allowing them to chemically
castrate themselves and it's it is
leaving them sad it is leaving them
deformed and ultimately they're not
better off they're they're told they're
lied to and said that you will be happy
um and that you're not going to regret
this and it's killing kids they're gonna
they're gonna wake up like you said when
they're 20 30 years old themselves why
did this doctor tell me that I would be
happy why did my parents go along with
this who was there to protect me
and as a society we need to we need to
be those people to protect them despite
their wishes it's crazy I feel like you
know we know we know the history of
certain medications like was it
thalidomide was that the name of the
drug thalidomide it was like an
anti-nausea medicine they gave to
mothers and the kids were born with like
no arms and their hands were just like
on their shoulders or whatever all kinds
of terrible defects and then you you get
a generation of people that have you
know that have to live this way we're
getting the same thing here I mean
people have said it's going to be not
too dissimilar to lobotomies the removal
of healthy organs and and their the
targeting of minors hey look you're an
adult and you want to make a decision
for yourself
ain't nobody there but you and God and
you know a a functioning Society should
do their best to to help and protect you
in the best way possible if you're a
child there is a bigger challenge that
we were just bringing up do the parents
have the right to consent to what
medical treatment they think would save
their kids life the question then
becomes how you have to actively Define
when something is legitimately going to
save a child's life challenge is there I
mean we should drink Mercury I'm sure a
lot of Medical Treatments we have today
that are legitimate May some point be
like oh that drug actually was bad it
was causing these problems so there's a
difficulty in navigating this because we
want to talk about parental rights like
in Florida what if a parent wants to get
their kid castrated does the government
then intervene and say no hold on what
if a parent wants to get their kid some
kind of treatment say you know some kind
of experimental medication that could
cure some genetic disorder and the
government says no does the parent have
the right to choose and like what are
those limits
if there's a legitimate role for
government I think protecting innocent
life is among the legitimate rules and I
think that that at some point that has
probably going to end up being arbitrary
but at some point we have to decide this
is where the state steps in
um
and I don't know where that point is and
the problem is you've got powerful
political factions in half the country
that believe the state should step in to
castrate the kid yes well because they
put a clock on it right so they want to
have you make the decision when your kid
is prepubescent because theoretically
going through puberty is traumatic for a
kid who feels as though they are in the
wrong body right I don't believe that I
personally don't believe this but this
is an argument that comes up for parents
right if you if you have a daughter and
your daughter identifies as a boy
getting her period would be traumatic
because she doesn't feel like she should
have it it's a it makes any kind of
gender dysphoria worse and that kind of
urgency and pressure is
terrible right no one makes there are
some people who make good decisions
Under Pressure but I don't think anyone
can make a good decision when he's like
how do I keep my kid from being
traumatized especially when actually you
don't know what the alternatives are
there are no Alternatives being pushed
on you it's being pushed on you uh I
think that's crazy personally I think it
comes I think of it similar to should
you be allowed to get a nose job when
you're 16 right personally I feel like
if you're a good parent you would say no
wait until you're an adult wait until
you're older I can make it but it knows
job doesn't sterilize you but I don't
think but it's permanent right you can't
put it back it doesn't sterilize you but
you can't then say I want my original no
yeah
we should be encouraging children to
make decisions like these life-changing
decisions should be made when they
themselves are adults I don't think that
because your parents can consent to you
getting a nose job at 16 means that the
child should anytime you have to go
under uh anesthesia and actually be put
out like that's there's a risk to it I
mean they are fairly routine but there's
a risk to it so if it's not something
necessary I think maybe the government
should say look don't do this to kids
until they're 18. be just because of the
risk of going you know complications
from surgery they're real doesn't happen
a lot but they are real so again if
there is a legitimate role for
government
um then protecting innocent life has to
be among it you know protecting the
borders protecting innocent life give
you courts and and that's about it but
it's easy it's easy to say but then what
about a medical treatment a parent wants
to get for their kid the government
won't allow
right so that
that the challenges it is not about the
law it is about the cultural values and
the left values child sex changes and
the right doesn't but there may come a
time where there's something the right
says like hey we need to give this kid
this medication for like I know spinal
meningitis something and if you empower
the government they could be like nope
and then you're sitting there being like
excuse me like my kid's gonna die get
him to stream like we're not going to do
it well and a lot of these laws that get
written in saying you can't offer
hormone therapy or whatever else they
have exceptions for kids who are
legitimately legitimately born intersex
right when they have X X Y chromosomes
or whatever I think for me as a society
it would be nice and I feel like this is
unrealistic if we could all agree that
ultimately any kind of permanent surgery
should be the decision of someone who is
in full possession of their rights so I
mentioned this before most minors aren't
in full possession of the rights because
they are under the custody of their
parents and so therefore we shouldn't be
leaving it up to their parents to decide
what happens to you there about it they
have to be an adult with full possession
have their rights to be able to consent
to any of these surgeries
I mean I I just think it's not even
about
it's not even about the child choosing
or the parents choosing it is literally
about our moral values period my moral
values are you don't give kids sex
changes have a nice day I'm not going to
I don't need to create any kind of weird
philosophical or or moral-based it's
like or or a legal basis for it where
it's like well the government shouldn't
be no no no no don't care sometimes the
government should sometimes they
shouldn't this is a case where they
shouldn't the left believes that the
government should make this stuff happen
and the parents shouldn't get a right to
choose I think that's crazy I think the
parents should also not be allowed to
choose in this circumstance I do not
believe parents have a right to choose
their children get their sex organs
removed that's just me but there are
certain circumstances where I think the
parents should have a right to choose
certain Medical Treatments for their
kids it is not a black and white
argument there is no simple answer of do
the parents have rights or do they not
it's not that simple the parents should
have rights in some circumstances and
not in others if the parents want to
think that you know making their baby
vegan is going to be good for them the
government should be like yeah it's
stupid you don't do that your baby will
die you can't you can't have vegan baby
I mean you maybe you can it's like
really really difficult but you probably
probably give your kid proper nutrition
or something like that government should
intervene where we deem it culturally
and morally pertinent the left has
different moral standards which we view
as demonic and that is a very serious
problem for our society because you've
got mothers and fathers who are like I
have three kids we're all trans they're
like come on man it is it is it is
statistically anomalous that a child is
Trans in the first place but for a
parent to have three and we see these
stories that means called CPS well and
the government does regulate it under
some circumstances right like you'll see
all these articles about especially
women in their early 20s being like I
wanted to get a hysterectomy and my
doctor wouldn't let me because they kept
saying what if you change your mind and
this is terrible I mean why is it that
under that circumstance the government
is like no you can't get a hysterectomy
and when it's about gender identity it's
like well okay you're 18. it's a good
idea like it seems bizarre to me as a
double standard maybe we just shouldn't
cut out organs that were there in the
first place unless it is absolutely
medically necessary thanks thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time